en jaune et rouge des filles du club de
l'ouest tourangeau face en bleu et jaune
au jocondienne pour la plupart des
joueuses les crampons on était chaussée
car le foot était une passion familiale
parmi des dix-huit mille licenciés en
indre-et-loire 2500 sont des filles et
ces dix dernières années les
inscriptions au féminin ne cesse de
grimper la passion est grandissante et
comment on fait pour être
ma passion et mes peut-être
métier
sur les 190 arbitre de la ligue du
centre seules 11 femmes le district veut
ainsi misé sur cette formation pour les
jeunes filles en indre-et-loire 200
femmes se sont positionnés sur des
directions de club et ce chiffre ne
cesse d'augmenter
le foot féminin se développe et les
préjugés sont mis de côté par la jeune
génération
c'est mieux qu'il ya quelques années le
foot féminin il se développe de plus en
plus et puis bah comme on vient quand
même des ados c'est moi les garçons sont
un peu plus mature etc
je monte abus a franchement moi quand je
dis
mais ce développement du football
féminin pourrait trouver ses limites
dans les infrastructures accueillir
filles et garçons dans un même club
c'est proposer des vestiaires dédié ce
qui n'est pas le cas partout aujourd'hui
on demande à nos politiques de pas
d'augmenter les capacités d'accueil pour
pouvoir justement accompagner ce
développement du football féminin et
comme le sport féminin si dans le
football où où les autres sports de
balle notamment
et bien écouté par nos politiques on
espère être entendu
autre requête du district développer ses
infrastructures pas seulement sur la
métropole mais dans le milieu rural le
vivier du foot au féminin